foreign  remember that story about Cindy you know  who when her Christmas was stolen she  knew what to do why Santa Claus why but  what if I said that's not how it went  down  you gonna be okay because we can turn  around right now no poor girl her mother  was killed her mind's name  did you ever find the Christmas killer  never got a reliable description of the  man  [Music]  okay  he is out there what if the Christmas  killer is back this  this cannot go through another Christmas  killer thing not again us folks down in  Newville we liked Christmas a lot  then the  North  it's not what is it the main one  slippery resolution he's a mean one  night mister  I'm not going to be a victim  time to roast this Beast  [Music]  you're a dead one mister